today's draft inspired by the 24th
anniversary of the firing of bill
belichick by the browns the draft is
people who could get better given a
second chance and i have exercised my
executive privilege here shireen to
expand it to anyone connected to the
national football league players coaches
executives anyone
you get the first question or you get
the first pick rather if you get the
trivia question right and this one comes
from the as sims would say what color is
blue category although i may just be
setting you up to to think it's going to
be so easy that maybe you get it wrong
bill belichick yeah
by the browns 24 years ago today who
followed bill belichick as the head
coach of the browns
when they returned to the nfl in 1999.
that red light's on
and i don't know
cindy brady oh sydney brady's back uh
it's chris palmer
wow
wow chris palmer
he didn't last long either
should have kept bill belichick
i don't know that i would have gotten
that one right frankly in hindsight but
since i had it in front of me it looked
pretty easy all right
first pick for me
i'm gonna go with
excuse me
i thought it was over my cough
apparently i'm not
first pick for me leslie frazier the
bill's defensive coordinator he was
coached in the minnesota vikings for a
few years took the team to the post
season he didn't even get mentioned in
this hiring cycle didn't even get
mentioned no interview no mention no
nothing oh the last time i checked the
bills have a pretty damn good defense so
hopefully at some point the ship comes
in for leslie frazier hopefully he at
least gets mentioned for another head
coaching job but if and when he gets a
second chance to be a head coach there's
a chance he's going to be pretty good
because he's been great with the bill's
defense and he took a vikings team that
was basically in shambles thanks to some
misguided leadership of brad childress
and yeah 2011 wasn't good 2012 was a
playoff run 2013 at the end of the
season the wolf family decided to move
on but i think leslie frazier could be a
very good head coach if and when he gets
a second chance to do it shireen
yeah and you're right i didn't even
think of leslie frazier when we were
doing this it's almost like he's been
forgotten in this whole thing and he's
been a very good assistant coach for a
really long time with a lot of different
teams and
he's one guy you look at that that you
do think could be better in his second
chance if he goes to the right situation
and it's always about that right
situation and that's why my second my
first pick is going to be the obvious
choice of josh mcdaniels because i think
that if he gets that right situation
which i think eventually is going to be
new england replacing bill belichick i
think he's going to be a very good head
coach and he wasn't in denver i don't
know that he could be much worse
considering what happened there and and
how he failed in so many ways in that
situation
but i think he can be a very good head
coach in the right situation and i do
think new england is that right
situation obviously the colts weren't
and teams are really leery of hiring him
now as they should be
but i do think he gets the patriots head
coaching job after bill belichick
and it really is such a strange
situation how this year the brown's job
doesn't go to him it goes to kevin
stefanski the giants job goes to joe
judge less accomplished head coaches
than josh mcdaniels getting their first
chances and you just wonder when that
opportunity for another head coaching
position is going to come to josh
mcdaniels and you know there's been like
a weird sense
and and i don't know what this comes
from
and maybe it's just the reality that
nepotism is such a part of the nfl
coaching industry but
i'm starting to think steve belichick is
going to be the next patriots coach not
josh mcdaniels i think the combination
of this sense that mcdaniels inevitably
is going to leave
coupled with you're seeing more and more
steve belichick i i just i i just uh for
whatever reason after 2019 i no longer
feel like josh mcdaniels is going to be
the natural replacement for bill
belichick and maybe it's because he will
be gone by the time bill belichick
decides to call it quits all right next
one for me and this is one that pops up
from time to time
um
and it's probably not going to happen
but i'd like to see eddie debartolo own
a team again
uh and you know and yes he deserved to
have the team taken away from him
because of what he did 20-plus years ago
but you know there are people around the
league who believe
that of the 32 teams only 10 really know
what they're doing and the other 22
don't know what they're doing in large
part because of who owns the teams and
the leadership at the top and how it
trickles down or otherwise to the lower
reaches of the organization and i'm not
going to name who's in the 22
but de bartolo when he was in the league
he was in the 10. he clearly was in the
10. he knew how to put a winner together
he knew how to be the right kind of
leader and it would be great if he could
find a way to put the capital together
and get the approval remember when he
got to the hall of fame shireen there
was a sense that it was moving in that
direction where debartolo was going to
buy a team i just think that it's gotten
to the point where it's so expensive and
i don't know anything about his
financial situation but it is
ridiculously expensive now you gotta
have so much money to to operate an nfl
team you have to be able to buy enough
equity you have to have enough money
laying around where you can actually run
the team during the off season when the
tv money isn't coming in but i'd love to
see eddie debartolo as a team owner
again
i'm going to play devil's advocate here
though the question was people who can
be better of that second chance daddy
debartolo is already in the hall of fame
can he be better than what he was before
you can't go in the hall of fame again
first of all the devil's doing just fine
on his own second of all you got a
pretty good point there you're up
all right my second pick i'm gonna go
with dennis allen you can't hold the
raiders against him a lot of guys have
gone and coached in oakland and been
failures he was a failure in oakland but
look at what he's done with that saints
defense i mean we never thought the
saints defense would be any good and it
is good it has become good uh with what
he's been able to do there and and so
aggie great dennis allen i think
deserves a second chance he's another
guy you never hear his name mentioned
anymore he's just kept like leslie
frazier he's kind of gotten forgotten i
mean we hear more about dan campbell on
that saints staff than we hear about
dennis allen and i think we should hear
more about dennis allen still young
still a really good football coach and i
think he could be a head coach again in
this league and be a very good head
coach again in this league he wasn't the
first time
and you're absolutely right there was a
stretch early in the year when the
saints defense was really good that his
name was being mentioned it really is
funny though
when when you see all the names that get
mentioned from september to november but
then in december
there's only a very small handful of
names that actually are mentioned when
it's time to figure out who's going to
get the interviews and allen's name
didn't come up at all and i agree with
you that what he's done with that
defense justifies consideration for
another head coaching opportunity for
dennis allen right the last one for me
and i don't think he wants a second
chance but if we're gonna be strict
about the actual definition of the draft
sharing people who could be better given
a second chance it doesn't say they have
to want it
nick saban could be better and would be
better if he had a second did i tie he
shouldn't have sandbagged until round
three
nick's saving if he had a second chance
could be better and would be better as a
head coach in the nfl the problem is he
hated coaching in the nfl his wife hated
the nfl existence they are made for the
college campus the college life being
the king and queen of tuscaloosa or east
lansing or baton rouge or whatever
mid-level to small city that is
dominated by the presence of a college
football program but if nick saban were
to return to the national football
league with the right quarterback and he
said within the past few years if they
had signed drew brees back in 2006 he'd
still be coaching the dolphins and
remember they could have had drew brees
sorry dolphins fans they didn't want
drew brees they and drew brees was free
and clear but he had 26 studs in his
shoulder they opted instead to give up a
second round pick to get dante culpepper
with the torn knee ligament trifecta at
the time but uh nick's saying i've you
know i've given up
hoping and and wishing that saban would
come back because you know the nfl is
already pretty exciting with one bill
belichick you throw a second one in
there just cantankerous curmudgeon i'd
love to have nick saban back in the nfl
but i don't think it's going to happen
yeah i should have won the trivia
question because i had nick saban as my
third pick in there too and i would love
to see nick saban back in the nfl as
well and i do think he can win at the
nfl level i know he can win at the nfl
level with what he's done in college and
i know he told jason witten one time
whitney told me this that
you can make a bigger difference in the
coaching ranks at the college level than
at the pro level but i think he could
make a big difference at the pro level
too if given that that second chance my
last pick i guess we need to go to a
player since we've had five picks who
weren't players uh and i'm going to go
with jameis wentz
you know
yeah there you go he had the 5 000 yard
season this past season he threw the 30
touchdowns got to get rid of those
interceptions got to get rid of those
fumbles seven pick sixes we know all
that but i think if he goes somewhere
else to the right situation i think
jameis winston can win in this league
all right now i'm throwing the challenge
flag the guy threw
5109 passing yards shireen
oh oh it has to be better dominated
but he threw five thousand one hundred
passing yards
yeah but he threw for more passing yards
than anyone who has ever walked the face
of the earth other than four guys drew
brees peyton manning tom brady and ben
roethlisberger i think he's doing all
right i really i really am amazed that
the buccaneers are genuinely ambivalent
about jameis winston look coach the the
the weak spots out of his game bruce
show us that you can that you can truly
be a quarterback whisperer be a
quarterback f bomber if you have to to
get him to quit throwing the
interceptions we've seen the good jameis
winston there has to be a way to get the
good and minimize the bad but maybe
maybe after one full season uh bruce
ahrens realizes that there's nothing
more he can do with this guy that he's
just destined to be a turnover machine
all right that's our draft you know
another guy was thinking of adding to
the list
um because he's only been a general
manager once but there's so many i let
me just say generally any general
manager that only had one job because
they get fired so quickly there's a
chance they'd all be better the second
time around isn't it amazing that
coaches get second chances but general
management very rarely some have some
have dave gettleman got a second chance
uh
and there's another name that i'm that
that's popping around inside of my head
of a guy who got a second chance but for
the most part shireen you get one shot
you work your whole career to get to
that spot you're a gm and if it doesn't
work out you're done and you're never
coming back
yeah and there's a lot of those guys out
there i think ryan grigson is a guy who
i think would be good
in a second chance as a gm there's
there's quite a few of them now out
there who i think could do a good job if
they got that secretary you're right
never really thought about that but gm's
don't get second chances you better be
very good at the job with your first
chance because you're not going to get
that second chance in the position that
they are in
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports